today United Airlines will retire the
original jumbo jet dubbed the queen of
the skies the Boeing 747 revolutionized
long distance air travel when it debuted
nearly 50 years ago but more efficient
aircraft have replaced it United is
giving the 747 one final tour Kris Van
Cleave is on board the plane at San
Francisco International Airport ahead of
its farewell flight Kris good morning
good morning the 747 is famous for its
staircase used to be a spiral leading up
here to the upper deck this is the very
last United 747 that will ever carry
passengers later today some 374 people
will be on board for its final flight as
it retraces the original United 747
route to Honolulu from 47 years ago take
a good look because after today you
won't see a United Airlines 747 land
ever again later this afternoon arguably
the world's most recognized plane will
carry its last passengers for the
airline this has been my whole life for
the last 17 years and it really feels
like I'm almost losing a family member
captain Tom Spratt will be sharing the
cockpit with captain David Smith as
United flies the 747 into the sunset
Smith recently brought his dad are
retired 747 pilot on a recent flight and
that brought him back to when he was a
kid I still remember my first 747 ride
where the seats and the very notes of
the aircraft were first classes today
and go up the spiral staircase and sit
on you know sofas and all that was just
something that will never be done again
in 1966 Pan Am asked Boeing for the
biggest airliner ever starting from
scratch and nearly bankrupting the
company Boeing's humpback double-decker
jumbo jet made its first flight less
than three years later the 747 entered
airline service in 1970 and was an
instant sensation
Michael Lombardi is Boeing's historian
Lee because of its size because of its
the economy because of its range it made
flying affordable United flew its first
seven
47 rout in 1970 from San Francisco to
Honolulu that iconic hump once housed a
fancy lounge for first-class fliers up
the spiral staircase complete with a bar
or even a piano
the 747s four engines carried the Space
Shuttle across the country and five US
presidents around the world Boeing has
delivered more than 1500 747 but today
the plane is less efficient than new two
engine airliners leaving its days as a
passenger plane numbered it's like your
first true love Henry Hart develops
first 747 flight was a family trip
that's him with his brother in 1970
he'll be on United's farewell flight
we're saying goodbye to a plane that is
an icon of air travel and epitomized
commercial flying when it frankly was a
more gracious more pleasant experience
than it is for many today Delta will fly
its last 747 flight later this year
Captain Smith is a huge CBS this morning
fan Norah hello from the captain all
right we like that and we like those
reclining seats thank you